approximately the role of an orbital in the molecule which is either occupied or unoccupied.
But how we do that is actually a little bit more complicated. So now we introduce something called the Jordan Wigner mapping to keep track of
anti-ymmetry and ensure that the correct statistics of the overall firmianic system are being obeyed. The Jordan
Wingner mapping is conceptually simple because of the one:one correlation between the orbitals and cubits. There
are other mappings that accomplish a similar goal including the par mapping.
The calculation of the par of a state requires considering multiple cubits. In the par mapping and some others, the
interpretation of one cubit corresponding to one orbital does not hold.
Now let's walk through a pretty simple example together to make sure that we have the hang of this transformation.
Say we want to calculate the single cubit interaction f dagger f. We start by plugging in our definitions for the
raising and lowering operators. Then we can group terms factoring out the identity matrix i and the 1/4.
As we see, we are left with terms that will look familiar to those dealing with commutation relations. This term here in
the parenthesis is nothing but i * the commutator of x knot and y. And don't
forget about the identity that we took out.
Now remember these are just poly matrices. Thus the commutator is wellnown. The commutator of x and y in
that order is simple. It's 2 i z. Make sure not to lose track of your negative signs and you'll get this as your final
result. At the end, we have successfully rewritten a firmionic expression in
terms of poly operators that our quantum computer will be able to understand.
Let's quickly discuss how we would implement the Jordan Wingner mapping in Qiskit because although I think it's
important to understand how the mapping and similar transformations work and see it worked through at least once, you
wouldn't want to have to manually do all this workout every single time.
Especially for large-siz systems in particular, we can make use of the sparse poly op function in kiskuit to
easily create the associated poly operations from a mapping. A nonoptimal
implementation will make use of nested loops and takes about 20 lines of code.
I'll link the code here for you all to explore. But at a high level, the steps are as follows.
One, use sparse poly ops from list function to create an identity operator
corresponding to the size of the parameter space to be mapped. Two, following the definition of the creation
and unhilation operators shown previously, use sparse polyops from list function to define x, y, and z poly
operations. This will map the firmionic creation and annihilation operators to cubit spin operators encoding firmionic
occupation number into the computational basis of cubits and three generate the desired
Hamiltonian in the polybasis by applying the above operators to the orbitals of interest. This usually corresponds to
the creation of an identity matrix which represents the core the non-interacting orbitals and then applying the creation
and annihilation operators to the active space with weights that correspond to the specifics of the problem at hand. As
I mentioned, this is just a high-level breakdown. The code isn't too complicated though, and you should now
feel confident in adapting it to other problems of interest.
Now that we fully understand the Jordan Wigner mapping scheme, let's see it in action in a more complicated setup. You
might remember this paper from a previous episode as well on how drawn dynamics. I'm not going to go over the paper again in depth, but please check
out the previous episode if you missed it and you're curious. In this example, Jordan Wingner mapping is used to
express the Hamiltonian of lattice sites with L sites for the Schwinger model in the absence of an electric field. Here,
it's a lot harder to specifically pinpoint what one cubit represents in this model because it's only the
collection of cubits together that make for something physical. In this context, a wave packet. Instead, you can roughly
think of the cubits as discretized pieces of space where here L is the lattice volume in which each element or
unit cell comprises two cubits. The firmic operators that we saw in the previous slide describe the amplitude of
the wave function on a particular site.
So our Hamiltonian contains these firmionic raising and lowering operators. But to implement such a
Hamiltonian on a quantum computer, we'll need to express it in terms of spin operators, not the firmionic operators.
So we use the Jordan Wner transformation. After applying the Jordan Wner transformation, our new
Hamiltonian becomes this equation at the bottom of the slide where sigma plus is the poly operator X + I Y and sigma
minus is X - IY. Once we have a Hamiltonian written in this format, the
hard part of a mapping stage is over and it can now be easily written to a circuit in poly operators.
In summary, we have discussed four examples of how specific mapping techniques have been used lately in the
quantum computing field. Starting from the simplest and working our way up to applying the Jordan Wingner transform to
Hadron dynamics. I do realize this is a lot. This material was very technical
and if you haven't seen it before, it can be very intimidating. The good news is that I promise it gets easier and
more familiar the more time you spend practicing. And that's really the name of the game and why I named the whole
series Quantum Computing in Practice.
This isn't something anyone can just pick up and run with from the start. It requires some studying, some
headscratching, and probably some frustrating times. But I encourage you all to sit with the discomfort and
really explore the questions that arise as you continue because this is the only way to really learn. Thanks for
watching. This has been episode 5 of quantum computing in practice. Next time we are going to explore how to simulate
a Hamiltonian from scratch. We'll see you soon.